Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sama Sambhogassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sama Sambhogassa
le Nobler, le Nobler, le Nobler, le Nobler, le Nobler, le Nobler, le Nobler, le Nobler, le Nobler, le Nobler, le Nobler, le Nobler, le Nobler, le Nobler, le Nobler, le Nobler,
Et c'est toujours bon de réviser pour les gens qui sont bien avancés.
Il y a trois choses au sujet desquelles nous devons être bien au clair.
Qu'est-ce que le Bouddha veut dire quand il parle d'attention, de conscience, de présence juste ?
l'on fait, comment l'on gère, ce qui nous éloigne de l'attention, la conscience juste.
Et qu'est-ce que c'est qu'on est en réalité en train d'essayer d'investiguer ?
Donc, pour comprendre ce que c'est que la conscience juste, il est bon de se rappeler des choses de la vie du Bouddha.
Donc il a quitté sa famille alors qu'il vivait ce qu'on appellerait de nos jours une crise existentielle.
Il était devenu conscient de l'existence de la maladie, du vieillissement et de la mort.
Et alors il est parti pour trouver une réponse à toute la souffrance.
Et plus particulièrement au fait de renaître sans cesse.
Et il a travaillé avec deux enseignants.
Et les deux lui ont enseigné comment développer des états mentaux très beaux.
Et ça, on trouve ça dans toutes les religions.
Avec la prière, les mantras.
Ou même avec la respiration.
Si vous continuez à observer la respiration et à vous absorber en elle, alors cela vous conduira à un état mental très paisible.
Et vous perdez la conscience de tout le reste.
C'est mieux que d'avoir un bain chaud.
Oui.
Donc, il a appris ça, mais malheureusement, quand ça a fini, il était toujours dépressif et anxieux.
Mais le problème c'est que quand il sortait de ces états, il se sentait toujours déprimé et anxieux.
Donc ça ne répondait pas à la question.
Est-ce qu'il y a une fin à la souffrance ?
Est-ce qu'il y a une fin au cycle des renaissances ?
Donc il a essayé une autre méthode qui était populaire à cette époque.
Et cette méthode était fondée sur la compréhension que c'était le corps lui-même qui était le problème lié à des mauvais karmas.
Si vous pouviez laisser le corps totalement, l'abandonner totalement, alors l'âme s'élèverait au ciel.
Et si vous faisiez un effort très fort
Pour ne faire du mal à aucun être vivant, alors rien n'allez-vous condamner à redescendre sur terre.
Ça, c'est la compréhension qu'on avait les djaïnes.
Vous voyez les moines djaïnes, ils balaient devant eux avant de marcher.
Ils ont même assez d'avis que quand ils tournent dans le sommeil, ils s'éloignent.
Et ils ont un tel niveau de conscience que quand ils se retournent, quand ils dorment, ils se réveillent pour balayer leur matelas.
Donc le Bouddha a essayé ça, ne pas manger, s'affaiblir aux points les plus extrêmes.
qu'il était tellement maigre qu'il pouvait tenir sa colonne vertébrale à travers son ventre vous essayez ça vous pourriez voir combien il était maigre mais malheureusement c'était juste plus de souffrance alors il a quitté ses compagnons
Et on peut l'imaginer sur le bas côté de la route ayant l'air très très déprimé.
il est dit qu'une femme était en train de passer sur la route elle avait des offrandes pour offrir à des divinités locales des choses sucrées, des gâteaux et quand elle a vu cette pauvre épave elle lui a offert et cela lui a redonné de l'énergie tiramisu
Et alors il lui est venu une mémoire au sujet de son enfance.
Oui.
Mais il y a quelque chose qui me semble très vrai sur cette mémoire particulière.
Mais il y a quelque chose qui me semble être réellement très très vrai à propos de cette histoire que je vais vous raconter, cette mémoire qu'il a eue, ce souvenir qu'il a eu.
Donc il se souvient, il s'est souvenu de son père qui faisait une cérémonie pour les semailles, pour ouvrir la saison des semailles.
Et il se souvient d'être absorbé.
La même concentration qu'avec les autres exercices.
Une absorption.
ce que mon père est en train de faire donc ça a été un point tournant pour lui dans sa quête au lieu d'essayer de trouver comment trouver le bonheur il a essayé de voir comment il se créait sa propre souffrance
Et c'est ça qui lui a donné l'inspiration de continuer à pratiquer.
Donc il a trouvé une place belle à côté du fleuve.
Sous l'ombre d'un figuier religieux.
À côté d'un village où il pouvait trouver de la nourriture.
Et il a mis de l'herbe dessous.
Pour être confortable.
Et puis il a pris une grande résolution.
Je ne vais pas sortir de ce siège jusqu'à ce que j'ai craché ce problème ou je meurs.
Je ne me lèverai pas de cet endroit avant d'avoir résolu le problème ou de mourir.
Heureusement pour nous, heureusement pour lui, en six heures, il a résolu le problème.
que ce souvenir, comment il a, à partir de ce souvenir, compris ce qu'était la conscience juste.
Quand on est enfant, on ne sait rien.
Donc quand on voit un papillon, nos yeux se fixent dessus.
On vit dans un monde d'émerveillement.
Et nous sommes si émerveillés par ce papillon.
Et on est tellement émerveillé que notre mâchoire inférieure tombe.
Et nos parents trouvent qu'on a l'air stupide, alors ils me tapent sur la tête en me disant, réveille-toi.
Et par cet acte, ils ruinent la chance de l'enfant de devenir définitivement libéré.
Et après que l'enfant ait absorbé le papillon, il se retourne vers les parents et dit « qu'est-ce que c'est ?
» Et ça, c'est une grande erreur.
Parce qu'alors les parents disent « ça, c'est un papillon ».
Et l'enfant dit, ah, papillon.
Et la fois d'après, quand il voit le papillon, il ne regarde pas.
Et il reconnaît, c'est la même chose que le papillon que j'ai vu.
Il dit papillon, papillon.
Et à partir de ce moment, l'enfant ne regarde plus jamais un papillon à part à travers la classification, le concept de papillon.
Mais bien sûr il faut passer à travers cette étape.
Il n'y a rien que vous ne regardiez que vous avez déjà vu sans le regarder à travers l'histoire que vous avez avec cet objet.
Donc, quand je regarde une bougie, je mets sur la bougie mon image de la bougie.
Comment est-ce que je peux faire retour à l'esprit de l'enfant pour voir cela comme si c'était la première fois ?
Et la manière dont nous le faisons, c'est par le fait d'exercer notre attention directement à travers les sens.
C'est pour ça que quand nous mangeons, nous mettons notre attention directement sur le goût, sur la langue, les dents.
Et quand nous faisons ça,
Et quand nous faisons cela, tous ces concepts disparaissent, nous faisons directement l'expérience de la chose.
Et ça, c'est une indication de ce que le Bouddha veut dire par conscience juste.
Donc, elle n'est pas
Donc la raison pour laquelle utiliser des notes mentales, c'est une manière de faire descendre l'intellect sur des choses très concrètes.
Et c'est comme s'il y avait le monde en arrière-plan et que l'attention se mettait précisément sur l'objet.
Et bien sûr, ce qui nous empêche de faire cela, c'est l'esprit lui-même et le cœur.
Toutes les turbulences dans le cœur.
Et par exemple vous êtes en train d'observer la respiration et tout à coup vous vous souvenez de quelque chose qui vous a irrité.
Et alors vous êtes dans ce nuage magique d'être en train de vous disputer avec quelqu'un.
Et alors vous vous réveillez.
Et alors vous vous dites...
Et vous revenez au corps, dans le corps.
Et maintenant, au lieu de pousser, repousser votre colère à l'extérieur, vous allez à l'intérieur du corps, ressentir la colère dans le corps, dans les sensations corporelles.
Donc toutes ces émotions, tous ces états mentaux, à chaque fois que nous nous sentons perdus, on revient dans les sensations corporelles ou dans la respiration.
Donc, on revient tout d'abord dans les sensations corporelles et si on ne sent rien, on va à la respiration.
Donc, toutes ces pensées, ces mémoires qui créent des turbulences à l'intérieur de nous, ce sont des énergies qui sont comme celles d'un typhon.
Un tourbillon.
Donc, ça, à chaque fois que cela survient, vous revenez tout le temps pour ressentir comment ça se passe à l'intérieur du corps.
Et vous essayez d'attendre jusqu'à ce que cela soit parti complètement.
Donc,
Donc ça c'est valable pour toutes les horreurs du cœur et de l'esprit humain, la culpabilité, la honte, la colère, la haine, etc.
La version...
Donc ça c'est plus comme un siphon.
Et cela nous conduit à cette doux oubli.
Il n'y a pas de souffrance dans l'oubli.
Donc il y a
C'est la vraie fatigue.
Mais là on parle plutôt de la torpeur de l'esprit et de la lourdeur du corps.
de ressentir la pesanteur dans la tête de ressentir la pesanteur dans le corps donc ce soir on ira plus en détail avec les obstacles
Donc en fait, quand on pratique, ce qu'on investigue, c'est exactement ça, les trois caractéristiques de l'existence.
Donc on n'essaie pas de faire de la psychothérapie.
Le fait que le cœur s'exprime dans des ressentis, c'est un processus.
Ah, c'est très cher.
Mais spirituellement, c'est cette investigation de la façon dont nous créons la souffrance.
Et il y a ce problème du désir.
Maintenant, la parole Pali est très difficile à traduire.
Le mot pali est très difficile à traduire.
Bien évidemment, un désir qui vient d'un sens de la bonté, du bien, est un désir que nous souhaitons renforcer.
La compassion, la joie, etc.
Mais ce désir
Mais ce désir particulier est basé sur la compréhension que si j'obtiens ce que je veux, alors je serai heureux.
Alors on essaie de collectionner beaucoup d'amis, beaucoup d'argent, beaucoup de vacances.
Parce que quand on fait ça, on se sent heureux.
Mais malheureusement, cette heure a devenu dépendante de l'argent, des amis et des vacances.
Et malheureusement, ce bonheur devient dépendant des amis, de l'argent, des vacances.
Et alors, qu'est-ce qui se passe quand votre argent disparaît, vos amis vous haïssent et il n'y a nulle part où aller ?
Dépression ?
Possible, yes, possible.
So, wherever our happiness is dependent on something, we can be assured suffering will arise.
À chaque fois que notre bonheur dépend de quelque chose, nous pouvons avoir l'assurance que la souffrance va survenir.
Donc, il nous faut trouver d'une manière ou d'une autre une relation plus douée, plus habile avec la vie, telle que nous l'expérimentons.
On pourra en reparler plus tard.
Ce qu'on veut attraper, ce dont on veut s'apercevoir, c'est ce désir.
Même ici, vous pouvez vous dire, j'ai mal au genou, je bouge.
Pourquoi vous voulez bouger?
Parce que vous ne voulez pas la douleur.
Et même alors que cela va déranger votre pratique, parce que cela va déranger votre concentration, même si on peut bouger sans altérer sa concentration, vous le faites quand même.
Mais si vous restez avec la douleur et avec le désir plus exactement, jusqu'à ce que le désir s'en aille, alors ce désir va partir parce que la douleur n'est pas telle.
Donc là, il survient une équanimité avec cette sensation de douleur.
Donc on commence à comprendre que
à chaque fois qu'on a des choses qu'on n'aime pas, on va essayer de trouver du confort pour trouver notre bonheur.
Ou le contentement.
Donc on est tout le temps en train de manipuler les choses.
Et sur l'autre côté, quand on veut quelque chose qui nous rend heureux, vous voyez, il y a un clignotant.
Et à l'opposé, quand nous voulons quelque chose qui nous rend heureux, il y a de l'agrément.
Et je parlerai un peu plus de cela avant le déjeuner.
Et la seconde qualité, c'est cette impermanence.
C'est vraiment pour nous attirer le fin de choses.
Donc, pour nous, il s'agit vraiment d'arriver à nous apercevoir de la fin des choses.
On est très bon à s'apercevoir le début des choses.
Donc, on est très bon à s'apercevoir, par exemple, le nouveau style de film.
Par exemple, on est très bon pour s'apercevoir de la survenue d'une nouvelle star de cinéma.
On sait exactement quand est-ce qu'on commence cet enrhumé.
Mais on ne sait pas ce qui est arrivé à ces stars de cinéma, elles ont disparu.
Et on ne voit jamais l'enrhumé, c'est juste perdu.
Oui, on ne voit jamais la fin d'un rhume, il est juste parti.
Qu'est-ce qui nous empêche de voir la fin des choses ?
Pourquoi on est toujours en avant de nous-mêmes, voulant savoir ce qui vient après ?
C'est parce que, quand on voit un fin, on accepte aussi, d'une manière petite, qu'il y a la mort.
C'est parce qu'à chaque fois qu'on voit une fin, on accepte d'une manière petite que la mort existe.
Donc chaque moment est une petite mort.
Et on n'aime pas ça.
Je n'aime pas moi.
Donc mon esprit est toujours dans le futur, en avant de moi-même.
Donc, en nous ramenant à la fin des choses, on devient plus confortable avec l'idée que tout se termine.
Les relations se terminent.
Votre partenaire, votre époux, votre épouse peut mourir avant vous.
Et il y a aussi un moment où nous allons mourir.
Donc pourquoi en faire toute une histoire ?
Parce qu'on meurt maintenant.
Les biologistes nous disent qu'on a un nouveau corps chaque 7 ans.
Un nouveau corps chaque septembre.
Mais on ne s'en aperçoit pas.
On voit les changements.
Quand on veut.
Enfin, à chaque fois qu'on y est.
Moi, j'ai eu sept nouveaux corps.
Merveilleux.
Non, non, j'en ai eu dix en fait.
Ah !
Mais je ne m'en suis pas aperçu.
Donc, voir la fin des choses nous accoutume et rend cela plus confortable, l'idée que, à un moment donné, nous allons mourir.
Et la troisième caractéristique de l'existence, c'est la question de l'identité.
Ça, c'est l'enseignement du non-soi.
Et j'en parlerai plus tard.
Vous mettez toujours cette phrase avec quelque chose après.
Je suis une femme.
Je suis un homme.
Je suis un père.
Je suis stupide.
Il y a toujours quelque chose à la fin.
Dans la phrase, quand vous commencez une phrase en disant je suis, vous mettez toujours quelque chose après.
Je suis une femme, je suis un homme, je suis un père, je suis stupide.
Et la question c'est, dans quelle mesure cette identité est réelle ?
À quel point ?
Par exemple, j'ai mal à la tête.
Donc, quelqu'un ici a mal à la tête.
Mais je vais dire, je suis malin.
Donc, une partie de moi possède quelque chose et une partie de moi est quelque chose.
Donc, on a une partie
Donc on a une identité avec le corps très confuse, pleine de confusion.
Moi je dis, je suis le corps.
Mais est-ce que je sais maintenant ce que mon foie est en train de faire ?
Non.
Quand vous investiguez votre connaissance, votre expérience du corps,
Il n'y a pas beaucoup que nous expérimentons directement.
Toutes ces identités, comme mon corps, mes émotions, mes pensées,
Toutes ces identités, comme mon corps, mes émotions, mes pensées, dans quelle mesure elles sont bien vraies, bien réelles ?
Donc cela devient un objet.
Quand nous sommes nés, pendant les premiers quatre mois, il semble qu'il n'y ait aucun objet.
Donc, quand on est pendant les quatre premiers mois, il semblerait qu'il n'y a pas d'objet.
C'est juste une douche d'information.
Indifférenciée.
Mais par contre, j'ai clairement la sensation, la connaissance de quelque chose quand c'est...
qu'une chose est plaisante ou désagréable.
Et puis, au bout d'un moment, de cette masse d'informations, mon premier objet arrive.
Et en général, c'est la personne qui prend soin de vous, votre mère.
Maintenant, pour rendre le monde extérieur complètement objectif,
Et pour rendre ce monde totalement objectif, ce monde extérieur, et pour me séparer de ma mère, cela me prend trois ans.
Donc, quand on a trois ans, on dit « je suis moi ».
Et c'est à moi.
ça vient plus tard, parce qu'effectivement ça vient plus tard.
Avec mes neveux et mes nièces, j'avais l'habitude de leur prendre leur boulet, en disant c'est à moi.
Et ils me regardaient avec beaucoup de surprise.
Ils étaient très en colère, maman, maman.
et bien sûr ce processus d'objectivation du monde extérieur continue ce que nous faisons
Ce qu'on fait, c'est de mettre le monde intérieur à l'extérieur pour qu'il devienne un objet.
Donc maintenant, je deviens conscient des sensations dans le corps.
Des émotions et humeurs dans le cœur.
Et je peux voir les pensées et les images de mon esprit.
Donc il y a une séparation de la conscience de l'organisme psycho-physique.
Donc cette séparation nous aide à devenir conscients du fait que la conscience est d'une qualité différente.
Donc ce processus de détachement de l'organisme psychophysique est le processus de la libération.
On en parlera plus tard.
Donc la conscience juste, l'attention juste, on commence avec le
l'esprit de l'enfant, sa manière de regarder.
Et à chaque fois qu'on est pris dans une histoire,
Quand on se lève de la posture de l'assise en méditation, on peut commencer à s'intéresser à l'histoire.
Vous pouvez écrire des romans.
Mais pas quand vous pratiquez vipassana.
Et puis on investigue les trois caractéristiques de l'existence.
Le désir erroné.
L'impermanence.
Le non-soi.
Non-moi.
L'identité.
Très bien, je peux seulement espérer que mes mots vous ont aidé d'une quelconque manière.
Que je n'ai pas causé plus de confusion.
Et que par votre investigation attentive, vous vous libérerez de toutes les souffrances.
Plutôt que plus tard.